hello and welcome to this video which is
a new rapid Chianti just playing light
key and we get a double vehicle see what
black wants to do then like have lots of
flexibility with the center pawns with
d6 with c5 and I'm trying to prevent a 5
mm black now has a couple of options 9b
d7 is one of them E 5 C 5c 5s and maybe
them the move that is valued best by
theory
I'm not entirely sure I haven't really
studied this for quite a while I played
more fun to see for lately didn't go
into that double shake at all that much
c16 yeah a couple of things I can do
here
C 492 a phone one couple of things what
I don't like is a 4 D 5 it's not very
likely to happen but ok I put the light
on - D - first that's a very flexible
move
one thing that's very typical yeah about
this opening is that there is no policy
for that makes it that makes them a big
difference that makes a difference what
difference does it make em it is that
that is an expression it's helpful to
know some small some songs what
difference does it make
and yeah the difference is that I have
nicely formed and now night seafoam is
not yet good but it's good also covering
for first and then right before the d6
is a weakness so I wonder if b5 but what
about b5
hmm why does that work isn't a five
hanging
hello we should take these guys
so currently so if i if i retreat the
bishop it's probably the easiest thing i
don't think he can take you for that
easily i mean that would lead to an
extremely awkward pin
I hadn't even technically working so it
makes sense to I think we'd want and
work with the e5 IDM push the pawn to e5
Jim did some extremely difficult a black
is upon down and there is no hint of
compensation they cannot grab before
ignite ex Bishop design came to 794 94
Queen D for chicken and that's that's a
piece Wow way to start work
the other sister is the queen
okay yeah that's probably not a game I
should upload or maybe just get a
rematch I know it's such a short game so
we're going to play a second game
why not and see what happens here so a
three that's early now a six is
something that I can I do I mean let's
let's check this a little bit
can I do something else entirely
yeah I think is fine yeah he does that
I'm not really sure if I should flick in
Bishop before in this position and kind
of tempted look into a tool I don't
think so just go back to 870 first and
then see what he's doing it's amazingly
hot ready in my office especially okay
slow t6
so let's see probably just developing as
good now let's quickly play usually you
want to prevent black from playing d6 to
d5 in such a position is there any
drawback don't think
I don't think so I mean after see takes
night eggs that looks pretty much forced
I don't think Jim Massey was hanging
after all it looks a little bit weird to
not take on d5 so she takes my takes
maybe I cannot have a digital kind of
feeling like I had that on the ball in
some earlier game and I liked it
initially and then I didn't like it so
much I mean you could argue that the
different pong should be somewhat weak
as the bishop is on g2 would it's not
easy to get some play and it's not clear
what my bishop a7 is doing him I'm a
little bit irritated that he doesn't
take on d5 immediately because CLL what
else I'm not really certain what else
white could do here c4 is hanging so
when you have Queen to b3 maybe but I
can't even take on c4 and play b5
probably against that yeah why not
that should work so c5 fair okay so he
takes at this c5 but also a bit of a bit
of a strange strange move c5 would have
been okay
let's save a bit of time and castle I
mean save a bit of time so that I don't
invest a lot of time and then I play the
normal move anyway AHA so it it seems
like he wants to
be able to play Bishop to h1 in case of
Bishop III yeah but I have a another
simple question to ask if I'm playing
this and play look the aid how is him
dealing with the threat against the d3
pawn that doesn't look all that easy
maybe you can take we can take with the
bishop and then threaten Bishop c6
Bishop takes d5 winning the pawn took us
a bit weird I also have Bishop g5 in
that case ok so he took with the night I
am going group the aid the question is
what worker look F da door look a d8 and
what is White's reply after 38 and
threatening I think I'm threatening to
take it
[Music]
hmm I don't I don't see anything great
for white after same membership everyone
doesn't look good I mean maybe he can
allow me to tag and just play on my
structure that's possible yeah I think
I'll do this I'm really uncertain here
the decision between route 88 and book
ft8
you can invest lots of time for for this
kind of decision but it's often best
just to go with your your gut feeling
and and don't really invest all that
much time in such a rapid game scenario
yeah what I wonder is if he somehow can
um just give the pawn for some sort of
compensation
don't exactly see how but
Jeff he has no mechanical way to
coverage
the only Amin okay Bishop to f1 maybe
this is better than it looks and it
looks pretty bad with this what am i
doing against that not completely
self-evident of my replies
Oh
going for some activity definitely make
some sense okay I can move the night
which that looks strange
I can I take five who take a six that
doesn't really make any sense I think
taking taking must be correct yeah now
this is interesting I can take you three
but at the NC seven is hanging which is
mighty mighty annoying so the most
obvious move with this one covering c7
still attacking these three and they're
also um maybe some discovered attacks on
the night possible
No
am i just threatening to take the pawn I
think I do
I'm just ready to take it okay so he's
opening this up okay I can move the
knight to a five
and just grabbing d4 is not bad pawn
takes Knight excited I can always at the
end play Bishop g5 and be better if I'm
winning this or if I have winning
chances is not clear and any other
options Bishop c4 is a move it takes my
things and expression takes Bishop takes
Queen takes Queen takes matters a
disbenefit book let's do it keep it
simple maybe I had something better like
985 but I just a for I don't think this
would have yet we've netted me all that
much
yeah we should take looks like the
normal move or is there something else
that I overlooked here like in c5 for
example but that doesn't listen to much
then you should take with the bishop
after he takes D form you just have a
pretty awful Bishop on b2 so he should
be happy to trade it so Bishop takes
yeah I think I'll going to take and now
I expect Queen takes if I take a couple
of times on d4 you can take b7 and this
ending should be I'm not sure it should
be better
and now Bishop g5 was my idea as
probably just draw off all this draw
it's a little bit on the disappointing
side
episode t5 t6 would be one be six books
here on them now that is not enough
okay I have to keep a little bit more
stuff on the board
so cover be seven okay now if you have
to be a little bit bit precise possible
him maybe this is a move preparing a
grave form I also have some background
issues we can't bring the King towards
the center I'll be back in a second
you
much time H four okay also on its get
the King into the game the King would be
really nice on c7 I cover the pawns to
get some water should be three that's so
ok so my key now is covering this and
the idea is loop f1 winning winning
stuff winning lame or so you move this
one forward and down here for Luke a8 so
let's see if we can keep the material
here this position will not be all that
easy route d3 it's also be five in this
position
he played this age for one solid it
didn't really help in the defense I mean
I'm not sure if he had something great
in order to strengthen his defense but
what he did didn't help
[Music]
yeah so what is he doing look t3 maybe
then Bishop c4 is a problem
and extremely helpful that my king is on
to 7/8 defense the beasts and weakness
and in many endings the king is ready to
go towards those targets
okay the other player may have left the
game claim victory called wrong yeah
maybe he just lost his left again mm
yeah but we had a nice conversation I
mean maybe maybe he's coming back
I can definitely wait for a moment but
you never know I mean in some of those
cases people don't even play from home
but play from their mobile phones or
tablets or whatnot and um it might
happen that they just lose connection
yeah I think I'll wait for a little bit
spits when I cannot wait the whole
formula that would be a little bit a
little bit lame maybe I'll wait until
it's not down to three or something but
it looks like it's not coming back
I know it's been okay so good that I
waited it's under so look a three plate
so look here look a8 look a 1 I go beat
5 he's going to shift his focus towards
um he said I am some entering a room ok
I wonder if Bishop d5 now is a good move
or not
maybe I can claim here he will go look a
one my ideas rook a6 b6 before and then
you should drop one of the columns ah
okay so he's not covering is going for
the calendar play okay in this case I
probably have to play - 85
the idea is not to play back to a 5 min
EST 5 medicine to play back to 85 and
then C and then play with the B 5 idea
but I'm just recognized when he has to
cover any porn someone maybe it maybe
hooks you form
no I still have to play five
[Music]
who create five I wonder what looking
one actually this is something I can do
I know that's a mouthful
I hope that he takes this editor hey
what's going on here
frisky what is that I have a real delay
here yeah maybe my computer is actually
overheating or something it's extremely
hot and I had had this on more than 100
degrees yesterday the CPU temperature
something that group a one at b5 this is
pretty straightforward
d5 I would take the in for Tom looking
one out like in d6 maybe he gets that
then then switching back to the b-pawn
is good
hmm never here isn't b5 just winning
stuff that oh I want you resigned okay I
have to take the door so I'm going to
stop the video pause the video just
briefly is it resumed yeah I think it is
so let's have a look now at this game
yeah
took her took a while we had the where
is it
computer analysis I have to click here
and then see what happens
yeah I had a I totally forgot it's a
Thursday here when I record this and we
have a we have a sale of goods right
from the farms nearby and they they come
every every two weeks to sell um
yeah vegetables and stuff directly from
from the nearby farms so it's pretty
nice and I usually buy some stuff that's
what I had to do they were at the door
so we had the English opening here and
he went a three oh yeah I think a six
not the only one for Falls but yeah yeah
I can insert this one but basically and
I can giving him this extra move the
question is does it really help or not
jump for me in some cases like after d6
which would be six that could be an idea
yeah like in the game the Rope maybe a
would have been vulnerable
let's have a look I hope the hissing is
not too bad at my computer have the
engine running and it's so hot that the
computer is probably overheating okay so
call me make it quick
d5 now and interesting the engine gives
d4 let's move I did not consider anymore
because the next day it makes perfect
sense very interesting
I cannot take because then d5 is killing
me
and not easily and whom that was good
maybe this is what he thought about he
took a while when he took a d5 and I
didn't spot this idea but it makes make
sense
interesting
I wonder what I would have done here
it's not easy to say I mean I don't
really have a great move folks sorry it
was screwing this up oh so default and
because this is not good I think because
I'm opening this out so taking is
probably not that great oh it's funny
that's funny neither engine is giving
this not as sufficient that's funny
it only gives right a slight advantage
okay I have some active pieces and male
is this f4 now I decided with equality
which is a really funny way to assess
the position where one side is a look
down at night f2 is a strong side ad d4
was good yeah right I mean maybe not an
advantage I don't know probably an
advantage but it's clearly better than
this
and here I think I'm reasonably
comfortable this is kind of normal and
now look savonia I suspected as much
that I probably can sack the pawn for
some activity that's this doesn't look
all that great and now deform
yeah Knight a5 was stronger and added
some steps you put R now you know I
somehow did not see this which is not
difficult and now I'm of course clearly
better very clearly better okay now
after he takes my in my advantage really
dwindled down to the point where the top
you to actually thinks is equal this is
maybe true we have objectively or like
mathematics is speaking with white still
has to be precise because he's got the
two weaknesses and meaning so much oh
yeah as I mentioned this is a business a
bit slow okay look a fourth bedroom yeah
I like this idea to get the King into
some some spot where does does something
and he I'm actually better
finally better this was 58 just back
yeah here and what he plays lutely one
he's okay after King here would be one
as I mentioned yeah that's also the
engine line this is just basically
counter-attacking and I probably cannot
win upon James tumbling to be fired
after which he resigned
yeah probably it is um it is close to
win as the default one remains weak okay
I hope you enjoyed this double feature
video thanks for watching